it's hard to get out of but so easy to
get into lucy not her real name has been
running drugs from london to the south
coast from the age of 14. once she was
stabbed by a dealer after drugs were
snatched from her more recently she fled
living in a trap house where drugs are
prepared after someone stole drugs and
she feared she'd be blamed what would
you say to young people who are thinking
about getting involved in county lines
drug dealing i'd say it looks like the
easy option
not not asking for help because people
don't like to ask for help
but honestly they're food banks and just
genuine people that are out there
and they're so much better
so seek help yeah get your money
elsewhere yeah food elsewhere yeah it's
so much better than getting involved
with people like that
this chaotic often brutal lifestyle that
children are sucked into is something
the government's trying to stop
and not just with police action the
prime minister who joined a police raid
this morning in liverpool says they plan
to close down 2 000 drug lines but also
invest in rehab for addicts too many
people have their lives blighted by
these county lines gang so
you've got to have you've got to you've
got to do two things at once you'll be
tougher on uh the county lines gangs
you're going to be tougher on the on the
uh the criminals who are doing it but
you've also got to make sure that you
you find those 300 000 people and you
help them away you can't simply arrest
them time after time and put them back
in prison again again you've got to do
rehab as well
the government says it will invest 780
million pounds to rebuild drug treatment
in the uk and predicts it will prevent a
thousand drug-related deaths reversing a
10-year upward trend so i think the
funding will go
a long way to rebuild the treatment and
recovery system in this country
we used to have a a system which we
could legitimately have described as
being world class i don't think that's
true anymore because of the the terrible
cuts we've experienced this is what i
give to the people and the little kids
and they go out for me three years ago
sky news first revealed that there were
2 000 county lines across the uk and we
spoke to the brutal people running them
the government says recreational drug
takers fueled this violent industry and
wants to deter them with civil sanctions
such as removing a passport or driving
licence
one former cocaine addict told me that
might add to the stigma of addiction and
discourage people from seeking help
all you do is make it harder for them to
find a way out and to find a way to
escape from something that's already a
stain taking away someone's passport or
driving licence is going to put all
sorts of obstacles in their way as if
they didn't already have enough
the government will invest more in
police action to dismantle county lines
but is this strategy enough to deter the
criminals and help the addicts and is
there enough focus on stopping
vulnerable people like lucy getting
sucked in
jason farrell sky news